magnus carlsen wins the Bilbao masters
final with a round to spare and finishes
with more victories than the rest of the
field combined big news about Baku it is
official team Armenia will not be
competing in this year's chess Olympia
and finally a new study reveals that
chess apparently does not make your kids
smarter Alexander and I discussed the
controversial results and findings of
this England case study chess Center
paring well with a nice Merlot and a
very subtle blue cheese since 1951 let's
enjoy
back from Bilbao where he was on site
with all of his great coverage and
videos is Peter Dockers Peter how did
the event roundup and what are the major
storylines for us ain't any good to be
back in Amsterdam although I must say I
am missing the pin shows the great
little bites of food - they never in the
bus country but yeah let's look Jess we
were talking about the bail bond masters
final and yeah it was Magnus Carlsen who
won the tournament's very convincingly
he scored four wins which was more than
the rest of the field combined and those
wins included his very first victory
over Michael portrayed the Dutch Grand
Master onigiri they had played 15 games
before and he had won the very first why
I can say 2011 then 14 rows and then in
this game Magnus finally won let's
quickly have a look how he how he
managed to beat him in this position
there's a bishop and night versus the
rook but there's not much material left
so it should be a draw actually but
already under pressure and in time
trouble on each put this rook on our own
square I should have paid queen a 6 here
and it's very hard for white to avoid
the Queen's being traded but the route
goes to a 8 and that was a mistake the
rook is unprotected there so it allows
the tactic Knight xf 5 next of course is
Queen takes d5 we check you cannot allow
that
so Queen is 6 had to be played but after
Queen g5 g 6 and for a few fair moves
yeah the attack was just too strong for
white so yeah
first win for Magnus and tournament
victory it was a good fighting game I
thought right from the start I knew I
was not feeling so great so I probably
wouldn't be able to calculate but I was
very much playing playing sort of the
man
it was was an interesting game we both
missed a number of things but I mean
dynamically it was interesting and then
you know of course it was was very nice
to beat him I would have much preferred
to win the first first game against him
because that would have been cleaner and
also felt better them but still it's
good now this month is being deemed the
month of matches with so many going on
why don't you tell us how many there are
and what the updates are on those events
yeah it looked a little bit like that
suddenly a couple of matches taking
place at the same time in Russia there
was a match between Boris Gelfand and
Ernesto in our Kiev and match between
vice world champion of 2012 and the
reigning European champion but yeah
galvans experience was was worth a lot
more he won this match with big numbers
actually and yeah the other side of the
globe in in China
ding Miran faced another Russian
Alexander group he shook and the latter
won the first of four games and it was a
decisive so we should won that match and
then at the moment a match underway
between Maxime for Sherlock Roth and
Peter Svidler in in bill it's part of
the animal build chest festival but
there's no super grandmaster tournament
this year there are three matches and
this is the main one on the first day
there were four rapid games and MPL won
that section two to have one and a half
and at the time of recording Maxime also
scored one and a half half in the
classical games and that means one Pro
and one win and he now has a life
writing of 2815 the Frenchman is doing
very well only eight players in history
did better than he has so far we will
keep our eyes on that one and keep our
eyes tuned to chest our calm / news and
all that you bring us each week Peter
alright see you next week
well Robert I don't know what Putin is
putting in the water in Siberia but it
is leading to some exciting play on the
board at the 17th boy cough ski Karpov
tournament and perhaps none more
exciting than the one covered here in
our move of the week Yakov nkow had the
white pieces against Emil set off ski
and played a move that immediately took
this game to the next level as far as
the destination and crazy town tell
everybody what that was and why this
tournament normally not getting a lot of
love because it's sandwiched between so
many big summer events was worth us
covering here in the move of the week
well while the tournament might be
overlooked Yakov Benko wanted to have a
summer lovin have himself a blast and he
went 95 check here against Utah ski the
idea is simple break open the king after
a takes d5 rook takes c5 well that 95 is
immune because Queen g5 check picks up
that Queen on d8 so instead she tossed
he grabbed the pawn on e4 and well y'all
go back and continue to type doubling
the rooks on the C file and after Bishop
e6 here
y'all could have missed his shot with
pawn d5 but Queen e3 was an acceptable
move and after Queen to d6 once again
this is where the wheels started falling
off he missed his chance with pawn to d5
yeah and missing his chance one more
time to open up potential tactics on
this diagonal really approved key
because when he played the move Queen
takes e4 Emil sitarski found King to d8
there may be some other moves but such a
nice subtle retreat of the king all the
sudden white felt the grasp slipping
away and just went on complete tilt
sacrificing the house but unfortunately
not coming up with enough eventually
being forced to simplify into an endgame
where he was just down a rook and went
on to lose the game so not very often
that a move is interesting and exciting
enough to be featured as move of the
week even though the person went on to
lose but maybe sitarski gets some credit
for his very nice defensive finds as
well look for more from the boy Koski
coming up on our blunder of the week
segment
breaking news Alexandra apparently Ches
does not make kids smarter or at least
that's what a study done in England with
three thousand primary students designed
to sort of challenge a previous study
done in Italy that said Ches does
directly correlate to better math scores
it challenged that study and said that
in in their findings there there was no
direct correlation no real concrete
improvements directly related back to
chess
but you and I dove into this and you
read the study along with the article
and and I understand you have some
opinions about maybe the methodology
that was done and really what the
approach was trying to prove that maybe
isn't isn't the best way to decide
whether or not chess improves general
intelligence tell us what you what do
you think about that so I'd like to
start off first by pointing out that the
title was slightly misleading so the
title was similar to chess does not make
your kids smarter when if you look at
how the study was conducted the research
question was more of does chest' have an
impact on math test results and the
reason why I don't know this is if this
is the best way to test the value of
teaching your kid chess is because first
of all in some of the cases they
actually took out a math class and
replaced it with chess so and then they
would test the results kids had on their
math exam this seems a little
counterproductive right kind of weird to
do that yeah definitely
counterproductive to be doing that and
the other thing that I think is the
worth mentioning is if you're doing a
test on the value of chess in schools
for young kids I think it would have to
be a study that takes more time and I
think you'd also have to differentiate
between specific intelligence so in a
subject like math and general
intelligence of thinking more skills
like concentration focus and I would
like to see a study that would be done
that would look more on kids who played
more chest how did their concentration
change versus kids who play chess how do
they do on a subject test on a
completely different subject right but I
guess the the headline of just chest
directly improved your standardized
testing scores for the bureaucracy of
Education real
doesn't just not as catchy as just now
it's like we're into it doesn't have
quite the same ring to it so they did
what they needed to do to get eyeballs
it certainly got our attention here on
chefs Center and we'll ask the fans to
leave a comment and let us know what
they think maybe your personal
experience with your kids playing chess
or maybe you are a coach who has seen it
used in the classroom effectively or not
effectively leave a comment let us know
and we look forward to more information
coming out about this as chess continues
to grow in schools worldwide one of the
biggest stories to hit the chest press
this week Mike of course is that it was
official a statement released from the
Armenian Chess Federation that they will
not be competing in the Olympiad this
year in Baku Azerbaijan obviously a very
big deal but I'm gonna let you take the
wheel on this story and give us the
details behind the decision just coming
across our desk you're right Danny they
will not be going back-to-back who
players like Levon Aronian will not be
participating unlike the last chess
World Cup where they did go we caught up
with the vice-president legendary
Grandmaster cymbalta Pushkin and the
Armenian Chess Federation vice president
had this to say the Armenian delegation
suggested that a non-controversial
locale be chosen so as to not cause
conflict as naturally any Armenian wish
to take part in the tournament in a fair
manner we regret that our offer was not
accepted and I regret that the
tournament will be held without the
recent three-time championship team
clearly an outcome that no fan of the
sport would like to see that was a
direct quote he also said that he
understands that no player that does not
feel to be safe in a particular
environment would be able to play their
best chess and as a former top ranking
player we can definitely understand what
he had to say Danny we've reached out to
feed a for their response about what
kind of alternate location was offered
and why that was not accepted and should
they respond to us we will tell you what
they said on the next Chess Center yes
of course disappointing news when no one
ever likes when the chess world is
divided in this way but certainly we
understand and respect the decision and
we look forward to more let's move on to
a lighter note last week Mike we touched
on the night over Memorial taking place
in Poland super strong event but we
never actually got to the final result
on who won tell us who that was and how
it broke down yeah more than two dozen
26 hundreds competed and an on second
GUI ago juju
he must have learned something by
playing of the legendary player himself
he wins with seven and a half out of
nine and Danny it all came down to the
critical 9th round game against
grandmaster melle Cumaean as black black
was pressing and in the end game it was
one seemingly innocuous King slip
Malcolm Ian moved his King from f2 to g1
it should have gone to e1 that would
have deprived cajuste keys bishops an
important diagonal and that's what it
came down to had Malcolm Ian held that
position would have been a two-way tie
with smearin and goose key but because
of the slip kaduche key gets top honors
all by himself
well congratulations big win for mr.
goose key now somebody else will get a
big win this week we don't know who it
will be but the British Championships is
getting set to start and it's a much
stronger field than it was last year
there in Berne myth and guess who Micky
Adams is going for his fifth career
title he won his first at the age of 19
the returning champion Jonathan Hawkins
is not there to repeat but even if he
was all eyes on Micky Adams and we'll
see how they do and competition ends
August 5th seems the only big name
missing is Nigel short but of course
should be interesting to follow the
event nonetheless and we will continue
to follow all that you bring us at chess
comm slash news each week thanks Denny
well Robert Victor bogan just can't get
enough of seeing himself featured on
chess Center even if it is for blunder
of the week
not long after losing the world Open
title in spectacular fashion here he
loses a completely winning attack to
Grandmaster Cora Bob from the 17th
Karmapa Cox key tournament in Siberia
going on right now tell everybody the
move he played here that took the
position from plus three to minus three
and one single blow here bogan played
the move rope to f1 which looks very
natural applying pressure on f7 but it
actually forced his own resignation the
reason why is that their Bishop takes d6
C takes D six Queen b6 check simply
trades off the Queen's and removes an
attack from the f7 square after the
Queen's come off black will indeed be up
a piece with a completely one position
so instead of rook to f1 rook e1
would have won him the game the reason
why is that now Bishop takes d6 C takes
D six Queen b6 check does not work
because after the Queen's come off to
the board
there's rook e8
checkmate and if the Queen does not go
to b6 forcing the trade there of Queen
d7 let's say now rookie seven hits that
work on f7 the game is completely lost
for black knowing that bogan is now on
complete tilt in his career losing
several more games at the Piekarski
tournament you can't help but just have
your heart go out to the guy obviously
someone needs to remind him it's not his
job to be featured on chef Sun or every
week from wonder of the week but either
way we we do look forward to all of
these exciting moments and shows that
even grandmasters go through struggles
right even top GM's like that can make
mistakes and back-to-back games so too
bad for Victor Borge on too bad he
didn't convert on this very nicely
played attack and too bad for him that
we had to feature him one more time on
blunder of the week
hello just calm and welcome back to the
real McCoy now this week I'm going to
talk to you about the one-armed cluster
bucket that is the Women's World
Championship cycle and believe me when I
say the word cycle I mean it extremely
loosely the cycle has this connotation
about something that occurs again and
again over time but in this case it has
more in common that drunken one legged
pirate going backward down an escalator
so the current cycle works like this on
even years they have a knockout
tournament the same kind of knockout
tournament that brought you world
championship gyms such as Cleveland it
has been yo've but that's only on the on
the even years I kid you not on the odd
years you have match play now if that
makes as much sense to you as maybe a
smoking section on the Hindenburg you're
not alone and it didn't used to be this
way there used to be completely normal
in terzano that fed into candidates
matches that would give you the World
Championship match and why did this
change will around the year 2000 the
Women's World Championship was changed
to match the men's which was different
because of the PCA split now even after
we repaired the Men's World Championship
we never fixed the women's why because
reasons so look into my eyes VA look
into my eyes I've got an idea for you
why don't we keep the knockout
tournament I know you love it I know
it's exciting but instead of having a
determine the world champion let's have
it determine the Challenger and then
they can play how you fawn at their will
so one little tweak and suddenly
everything makes sense help me feed a
help me end the madness
Paula Cole once asked where have all the
Cowboy's gone and we got the answer for
her right here they're living in time
trouble you ready to cowboy up rock on
Danny
Johan Solomon 19 year old Johan Solomon
just won the Norwegian championship
Purdy young superstar on the rise has
the magnus carlsen boom in Norway begun
let's see how to compares Fischer won in
72 us one Olympiad golden 76 so in
Batumi 2018 would we see Carlson AG
distinto and Solomon win gold that's the
timetable
next up party cardrona volley wants
chest in the Olympics Danny is that a
good idea I think it'd be a lot harder
to catch the Zika virus playing indoors
so why not just seems to fit right in
now the poi cough ski Memorial is
underway this seems to be the strongest
tournament every summer that just never
quite gets the love it might deserve why
do you think that is I have a theory
it's called 3,000 kilometres east of
Moscow in the middle of Siberia just a
theory night ash smear in Mississippi on
ooh all crusting 2,700 will they get
back over that threshold you know with
old guys on the rise seems like a
renaissance I can't guarantee whether
they will or not but I'm gonna move on
to the next question and hit you hard
with Ronda just lost a big game in fact
it was featured in our surprise of the
week last week to Silvio deny love and
it makes me wonder will he ever get
close again after losing so many points
to 2,700 he was at 26 99.8 but you know
what
Kedarnath once told me that grande de
zuñiga has never read a chest book so
time to hit the books Julio lastly Caden
trough became the first Grandmaster ever
to get the Boy Scout Eagle Award Danny
were you the first I am to get the award
no I never finished my Eagle Scout like
every other middle-aged depressed father
I'm living through my kids Mike like
every other journalist we have on chest
comm you rock it each week and I will
see you on next week's chess center
thanks Danny
you
at the Pocock's key karpov tournament
boy coughs key sounds like Schlotzsky's
I could really goes for a deli sandwich
right now sue go for a sandwich right
now I got a stop recording Cheston or
I'm hungry but it is leading to some
exciting play on the board at the 17th
karpov boy coughs key tournaments say
that five times fast what matters is
that we're gonna have to review this
game five times faster than we normally
would that reference makes no sense I
was trying to recover from a mistake
mate
so instead after Queen out oh my god
well after a beautiful attacking game by
bollig on he really just made a mistake
by one laughs okay I'll do it again
I got this he's not long after being
shown to lose the world Open title to
pop in Grand Master that was horrible
gentleman start the coy cough ski the
17th for the cough ski carp off Memorial
but carp is not dead is that a thing
okay I got a restart I was eleris
Dani after two features in blunder of
the week and three straight losses
I think Bo lagoons gonna have to change
his first name from Victor to loser
and here in this game can I say that in
my left we had the giggles we have to
stop control am I allowed to say that on
complete tilts we need to remind him
he's not required to get featured on
chess center every week as part of his
professional chess career but we do
appreciate the trainwreck of moves
doing so well
oh we've completely lost it man
hello just calm and welcome back to the
real McCoy oh my god I just spit all
over the camera